Boston Province and the surrounding New
England areas we have a major alert for
you and we ain't talking about the snow
no we're talking about a low ticket
warning come out and see the live show
baby yeah guys it's a great way to
introduce your friends to the show grab
the crew grab the home he's grabbed the
bozos come out uh there's still some
tickets left for December 6th in
Providence at the second show out of the
Late Show in Boston has a few tickets
left get them now let's party do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it's our little show
we sit there with your favorite
comedians and we find out that you're to
be classy yeah perfect just a big old
piece of trash that's right I'm your
hostage Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antuti's basement she just caught me in
the face with a snowball oh boy
left-handed too yikes I didn't know she
could do both Southpaw huh dude she got
some heat on that thing my co-host is
coming at you from across the table he
is the CEO of Ru garbage he is an
international businessman he's not to be
tripled with in the Board Room the
bedroom or the bathroom Kate puts you
know what I mean give it up for KJ it's
Kevin James Ryan Hey gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure
your rate if you subscribe over there on
iTunes full video available on YouTube
as you know those numbers are turn
around cooking cooking cooking cooking
maybe I [ __ ] love you smoke alarm
over there
um also because of my poops
um and obviously the greatest website of
all time uh shout out to Jack uh Jack
Conte Sam yam there Sam all subsidiaries
the two greatest people in the world
enjoy the holidays we love you Elon Musk
I say kick rocks I'm a Sam yeah that got
the kind of guy take that put that in
your pipe and bite down uh patreon.com
we got the best content out there go
check it out and having a nice quick
shout out to our producer short and air
uh-huh the magic man makes us all look
good works the ones and dues crosses the
t's dots the eyes it's T-Bone McMuffin
Toby McGowan everybody hey what's up
dudes hey T-Bone want to give a belated
shout out to the Toronto Argonauts
winner of the gray cup in the CFL oh man
this guy former owner Mr John Candy sure
on the Argonauts really a little bit a
little piece of that they played their
Super Bowl on a field that still had the
soccer lines on it oh man remember
watching and watching a game back in the
90s with the baseball diamonds oh my God
I feel like you guys are gonna get
bigger bruise you're gonna skin your
needs your Raiders yeah it's like dude
get the grounds crew out there will you
throw down some sod it's Sunday football
they would also they would also gets
[ __ ] smashed by a [ __ ] D-Back they
would would also have the bad shade like
to have you feel it would be in darkness
we caught this oak tree down I'm trying
to play a game I used to hate that was
that was signed to not off on the couch
and fall asleep or see what's going on
over there on Star Trek the Next
Generation see what's see what's cooking
with this guy really walks in both
worlds a jock who loves deep space
I wanted to ask what do you want to ask
with all the you know the turbulence
going on whatever Twitter have you
thought about it what buying a social
media platform no making a move you know
having a meeting talking to him maybe
saying what hey and verify me what do I
need right now what would you offer him
at this point you go and you lowball him
right and buy Twitter 10 12 G's yeah I'd
have to [ __ ] I'd have to cash them
some things out too to be that liquid
I have to call in a couple of savings
bonds dude sweetie find me down a
[ __ ] Johnny's pawn shop with the Kia
um yeah no I don't think I'd make it all
for all I don't have any money what are
you talking about that guy's got real
cash does he
think so yeah I mean I think he's worth
like 50 billion dollars or something
isn't he I heard it was all Investments
card tricks I got something for you as
you lay it on me as you know here in New
York City washing your laundry is a big
to do it ain't easy peasy you know what
I mean it's about to be the thing of the
past for old uncle Hank I know all uncle
Hank got a new apartment he's gonna have
a [ __ ] washer dryer in unit in the
unit that's [ __ ] I mean you know you
know you're really doing all right when
you got that going on in New York oh man
I'm excited that in a dishwasher I've
been washing my my clothes in a
dishwasher coming out smelling like God
a couple of fish bones in the pockets
I've noticed your finish has been
absolutely fantastic
um I had no spots on my shirt
um I know that we're just I know that
I'm just going to become one of those
guys that gets dressed in front of the
dryer though that's what's gonna happen
I love that I've done that every any
time I had a washer or dryer in my
apartment yeah wake up in the morning go
down there throw it on for a couple
minutes go brush my teeth come back
those people just have that what do you
mean they just got washer and dryers
sure yeah it's a very nice thing to not
have of course of course you're gonna
have a washer and dryer and squatters
rights while those rent checks
and closing their cycle to mine you
can't put a deadbolt on my dryer how am
I supposed to get dressed call the
sheriff I saw a video of squatters
getting kicked out of a place man and
this guy was really [ __ ] selling it
I'm gonna give you the GoPro so when it
happens we get the content this guy was
yelling up to his girlfriend yo you have
that receipt a receipt for what yeah you
mean the lease
Dirtbag no shirt on gut hanging out
[ __ ] basketball shorts hanging off
his ass he was yelling it was a nice
house too they had cameras set up they
had [ __ ] power running to the
neighbors yikes it's tough that's not
squatting though that's just breaking
into somebody's house squatters when you
when when you were uh a good tenant at
one time they need to stop paying the
rent that's a squatter now I think a
squatter is also classified as like you
go into a house and no one's living and
you just start [ __ ] living there and
you can do that there's some legal I
know squatters rights in New York are
very
um very that's lenient for squatters I
think I don't know what the time is if
T-Bone can look up I live here now yeah
it's just kind of that thing no I'm
telling you I live here now okay good
luck getting me out here on the lease I
know exactly what it is because my buddy
during the pandemic found someone moved
out of an apartment told him that all
the units were unlocked he went into the
unit set up a cable bill one month you
have to be able to prove that you've
been living there yeah it's like crazy
set up the cable bill one month one
month later he moved all this stuff in
stayed for nine months rent free
crazy that's [ __ ] up yeah pretty
scumbag-ish yeah oh it ain't great
hanging out with those hippies on the
Lower East Side did he have HBO what
kind of package are we talking about
can't pay can't pay rent but he's got
showtime and [ __ ] stars
got Encore cook who had Stars growing up
that's like the Kennedys we would get it
free I think at some points it would
come on for like two weeks
are you talking about the The Limited
trial that hit you with all of a sudden
I don't remember I don't know what we
had free HBO for a couple of weeks with
that [ __ ] man that was a sad day at the
foleys when that that turned off cable
now it's just I
to me and again this just could be my
perspective but like to call a cable
company in the night like you never
spoke to the company really now you're
like call up whoever you're you call it
Verizon you call up [ __ ] Time Warner
you call up Comcast
I don't remember my mom ever being like
Oh I'm gonna call the cable company oh
my mom called them all my mom for what
to [ __ ] about the bill uh my fat son
yeah he's complaining about her life bad
I got a flat tire last week you believe
this she got that in the astrology
hotline mixed up
Miss Cleo
have you or anyone in your family ever
called Mrs Cleo I am that's happening
put that on the list I called the Dirty
lines once or twice the party lines the
chat line sure man I never made sense to
me oh still made a lot of sense to me
they'd get you at like 11 o'clock on a
Friday night you're sitting there are
you high or something nah just [ __ ]
fat little horny kid what age we talking
15 16
13. you know you know you're gonna get
caught right so so what what are boobs
like are your boobs bigger than mine
I'm an oil tycoon what do you do
oh yeah you knew it was just some
[ __ ] whale sitting in like some
apartment somewhere like yeah I'm hot
so did they
yeah my dick's three feet I swear
you could probably see it from where
you're at right now I got here on my
balls you're my butthole
yeah I got caught up in that yeah yeah a
little pervert
yes I am his old freak
I think Patty did catch me and she
started crying she was upset why would
you be calling like that I don't know I
don't know if I got a stinger cooking
and no one was home
you [ __ ] canceled show time I don't
know what else to do man
never well with the blood pump through
your body never will the hormones be as
active as back then when you caught a
little titty on Showtime or you do the
scramble that played a scramble I didn't
really have to do that because at that
point we had the internet you could at
least get a picture or something you
know what I mean you could at least go
to like you go download a picture I love
you or uh lucky little brats uh I mean
that you know figure 13 or whatever I
was uh yeah the internet at least AOL
was banging e-bombs world the whole nine
sure we had DirecTV and they would show
you the first two minutes of the
softcore movies really which I didn't
mind I was just in there cranking into
credits
and who is the [ __ ] Director of
Photography on this one you just hear
the music
yeah no kidding you gotta sit through
half of the aerobics class
before they hop in the showers I
remember them being like
one and two and three and four you're
like let's go get that quick
somebody pull a hand somebody's brain
and Ankle yeah
one of these broads needs a massage I
know that let's go Holland's again your
quads look a little tense yeah get me
out of here
um yeah I uh [ __ ] wasn't gonna say I
didn't mind I remember like you would
get that so the softcore stuff on like
HBO or what you know HBO didn't really
have that software the Covenant was in a
lot of that stuff was it David Duchovny
yeah
um but people would be like I remember
my people would be like that's not real
sex or whatever there's no real
penetration or whatever I don't pay
buddy it's paying the bills I can use my
imagination I know bacon bits ain't real
either no but I'm still dumping them on
my salad the rubber's hitting the road
baby let's go what are you talking about
not real sex I'm 13 I'm in my bedroom
this is real as it gets yeah I got news
for you Ducks can't talk either I'm
still watching DuckTales I remember
people you look dude I'm like what else
are you got that's [ __ ] yeah what are
you doing I know I like a storyline too
which I've been on the record of I love
a storyline yeah I want to know why the
Plumber's pants you know what I mean
love a good storyline that's what you're
remembered as a kid the story lines up
David Duchovny red shoe diary red shoe
diary also starring Matt LeBlanc Joey
from Friends
and Jackie Chan did a sophomore movie
with my team wouldn't mind seeing those
three get it on huh talk about Rush Hour
am I right thanks Second Chance hitting
Mac LeBlanc in the face with the broom
and stick it
it's the only way I can come little
parkour porn that's what I'm talking
about
that's what I like to see yeah man red
shoe Diaries there was another one that
was on Showtime that was real real spicy
too not red shoe
I can't remember the name of it it was
hot it was like the penthouse
to Playboy was it Sylvester Stallone in
the party at Kitty and studs yeah he did
that before Rocky to make to like pay
rent or to get Rocky made he like did
that yeah I remember he was in a tub or
something like that
and there's a scene where he's in a tub
I don't know
it couldn't have been set in a more
unattractive way or something like that
hey Rocky's in a tub showed his butthole
in a tub
good stuff what were you gonna say
though I apologize no it's all right
good diagram good digression
um rude thoughts yeah right by impure
thoughts yeah right that was another one
impure thoughts that was a movie Jesus
Christ the kid watching his buddy's mom
take a shower
oh man like [ __ ] IMDb for dirt bags
yeah
softcore Hank over here that's what they
called me I like my dirty movies a
little cuddling
I don't like all that boning that you
like stay for breakfast she's a lady
what are we doing here
come on I wanted to ask you like we were
saying uh I'm back on uh you know doing
laundry in New York like we've said
before it can be quite a headache yes
um and we've been running and gunning so
much on the road that like I've just
been doing like what I need for that
week right can I say this please it
sucks regardless it sucks if you have
them do it it sucks because they they
they put everything in a a kiln
basically on three million degree heat
and it comes out everybody's clothes
smells that smells the same uh and if
you do it yourself it's just there's
something not it's tough it ain't great
it's tough so like I have I've just I
have like one hamper that I've been
going through of like you know it's got
like
10 pairs of underwear 10 pairs of socks
10 it's just been like cycling all that
stuff through you know what I mean you
have a hamper yes what kind is it like
the dorm room foldable one oh no I'm not
[ __ ] what are you talking I'm not a
freshman at State don't act like you
ain't looking at that when he walks out
that door yeah he's got a hamper on him
a dump her on me nice little turd cutter
I got cooking
I'll call him Kayla back home no we have
like one of those like uh it's not
plants it's more like cloth we have we
have two she has one and I have one do
you
no I have a trash bag Trader Joe's bag
what about you buddy I'm a Trader you've
never even shopped at Trader Joe's you
stole that from somebody
[Laughter]
I have a Neiman Marcus bag I use Trader
Joe's with two e's Trader Joe's
Trader Johns
oh that's a good one holy in Philly yeah
um no we haven't I have a nice uh wicker
whatever it is
um
thing that's overflowed with clothes
yeah and trash and it's like busting at
the seams I just kept I could just keep
pushing it down um so I you know I I've
always been doing mine we have it in the
building downstairs in the you know on
the first one you're doing the birds too
you do everybody's no we're all
different schedules because like the be
times when I just need if I'm doing it
I'll go hey I'm doing laundry do you
need anything to throw in with mine sure
like yeah get me out of this pinch I
need these jeans or whatever
um she'll do mine from time to time but
not really I don't like how she does it
it's a big thing in the house
I don't like how she does it she doesn't
let it get dry enough
huh I need to [ __ ]
that would freak me out I know like that
stinks that's something that a couple
should know before getting involved and
I was thinking you know what else a
couple should know before getting
involved how do you like your steak
because if if I think they would know
that I mean that'd be weird if you're
[ __ ] living with somebody you don't
know how to eat their steak but I'm just
saying that should be because she's
medium rare he's medium well whatever it
is you can't split a porterhouse then
you jam everything up
that should be what that should be the
first question on Tinder how do you take
your T-bone yeah I take them over there
with the buttons
uh yeah sure I mean but that'd be weird
if that's if that that truth is coming
out deep in the relationship you've made
some wrong that's not your biggest
problem if you're finding out five years
in how someone eats their steak
something you got three kids a mortgage
and you're going wait let me get this
straight
you don't like it medium rare this whole
thing's a shame
um no but I learned that from my my
whole family does everybody's my mom
always only does her stuff and then
my stepdad stuff's all separate for real
everybody keep kept keeps it all even
growing up my mom would do like my
laundry
and then I we started doing ours real
young which we you know on record saying
um so we all had to just do our own I
wasn't doing my brothers I'd be [ __ ]
crazy the 11 year old doing your your
brother's laundry sureless there's a
little cash involved never I could be
bought back in the day um you can't even
do yours now and put some money on the
table I'll take care of it um so I've
had just so much and I was like it all
backed up I'm like all right I gotta
[ __ ] get I gotta do so I took it all
to the uh
drop off the fluff and fold fluff and
fold which if you're not familiar in New
York you go you drop it off the next day
they charge you per pound you go pick it
up and it's like
[ __ ] hermetically sealed vacuum
packed perfectly it's [ __ ] it's real
nice it's way nicer than you do it those
people were packing QPS oh man
it's great like the cartel
[ __ ] it's like the military did it
it's [ __ ] fantastic put your socks in
some fake avocados
I can't go back dude it's [ __ ] I
can't go back to doing my own lawn as a
fat so you're still you can do that
though I just tell them to dry on medium
all my shirts are dryable shirts
uh you know all my stuff gets dried I
just tell them dried on medium and I'm
sure they're gonna [ __ ] it up last time
I stopped going because it came back
everything came back with [ __ ] oil
stains all over it like they like washed
it with like ball bearings or something
it just looked like you know Pizza
[ __ ] pizza sauce got all over
everything but
my question is we've deviated a bit my
question is do you tip that person oh
yeah really yes Jesus this guy I know I
did tip them but like
I'm not sure because I don't think the
person working the counter is doing that
it doesn't I know I understand yeah they
are yeah they are I don't think in mine
um listen I'm telling you I'm just
telling you that's definitely a pulled
house there's an office not an office
but the somebody sits at a counter
they're not back there's other people
working back there folding oh hold on is
is your is your place does your place
can you do it yourself at that place too
yes huh
yeah yeah I would say I do tip but I'm
just going like
I don't feel like the guy
I go keep the change with whatever it is
it's for the girls who or who's ever
done guys yeah yeah
ladies usually the ladies that run the
show sure I just don't feel like it
always makes it there I don't know it's
it's uh they don't have a tip box on the
counter no huh
T-Bone says no no way that's Shifty
tipping is for service industry people
who don't get paid a livable way no no
I'm telling listen
you haven't been a city that long you
tipped you tip the laundry people 100 I
don't disagree I don't I'm not
disagreeing but I do think that's a hard
job
sure sure they rely on those tips
today yes okay yeah I can't I can't pick
up the laundry you tip now I don't know
if it should be going to this jerk off
sitting there doing nothing that's what
I'm saying see I don't know where you're
going my place I go to a nice
establishment it's a nice establishment
uh the place near us you can do the
laundry obviously there's usually one or
two uh ladies working there and they'll
they'll they'll be doing something you
come in grab you know give them your
ticket they'll come behind the counter
and they'll take care of it here that's
for you guys
that's how we do it oh yeah that's what
I'm saying I don't have that it's weird
that's what I'm saying I don't have the
like hey this is for you thank you I
don't get that moment
what what is it a chain it's an apple
piece yeah who is just the guy taking
the receipts yeah just somebody who
works The Works hey yeah I mean I don't
even get to see like I you know it's all
the way in the back I don't know who's
doing what back then what's in the back
they're all doing it back then it's like
a little separated I don't get to like
I'm not like I don't walk by them hey
thanks Tommy Megan whatever you know
what do you know about that extra Baby
Oh you mean the slimmest and smartest
wild in the whole goddamn world you
probably got some some junk in your
pocket I got a big Costanza wallet
cooking I got I got crackers and peanuts
in there yeah gang does your wallet
still look you got a growth hiding in
your pocket it's time to upgrade baby
with extra do yourself a favor the
world's smartest slimmest wallet comes
in enough varieties to fit any style
yeah they were nice enough to send uh me
you and T-Bone all got a little care
package they took care of The Three
Tenors the cards pop out yeah it pops
out it's like a Quick Draw McGraw you
hit the button and [ __ ] six things
flop out you got all boom bang whatever
you need it's easy peasy uh and uh Black
Friday is their biggest sale of the year
with up to 35 percent off-site wide so
get over there and with up to 40 off
select Black Friday bundles makes the
perfect gift for someone on your list in
need of a refresh if you got a husband a
boyfriend a girlfriend whoever can use
it yeah uh they have a 45 Day free
return policy and a 12-month warranty on
all products look at that that's pretty
good shopping at Exeter is a no-brainer
baby take advantage of exter's bundles
with up to 40 off their best selling
items get 35 off exeter's wallets Black
Friday sale when you use the use our
Link at
shop.esker.com garbage and use code
garbage that's shop.exter.com garbage
promo code garbage do it Camp it's Helix
time baby oh the best of the biz I
jerked off at one earlier today no big
deal with that the best night's sleep
you ever had gank do yourself a favor
get over to Helix take the quiz they
analyze how you sleep when you sleep hot
cold light whatever it doesn't matter 45
minute quiz no you dumbass it takes two
three minutes we talked about this
before before the show here no you know
what the deal is you got one then you
bunked up and you got another one I know
they sent you one it was so good you
bought one now if that's not an
endorsement I don't know what it is Hey
listen hey cut the check hippies
endorsing things over here it's
fantastic best night of sleep I ever had
in my life me and the bird took the two
minute sleep quiz we got tagged up with
the Twilight mattress fantastic I feel
like a grown-up it's the first time I
had a real mattress in my life every
other time I've been sleeping only you
know your dead ants mattress or
something no kidding something you
bought it bought at a yard sale but not
a sleeping bag is a comforter and here's
the turkey Helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
three pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com garbage Helix sleep.com
garbage with Helix better sleep starts
now do it do it I do think
we are getting to a point
where I just you have to tip for
everything now which is pretty crazy
those iPads
where it's like hey choose what you want
I'm like I just bought a pack of gum
here and now I gotta tip you three bucks
on it they're holding your coffee
hostage it's crazy
coffee I get but I gotta think do most
people tip the barista yeah
they got to be making crazy money then I
don't think so I think it's like a
bartending job you make like a dollar or
two on a drink how much you think
they're serving a drink or serving in an
hour that's gotta be a lot I mean you go
most coffee shops there's a line
yeah you know what I mean that's gonna
be more than what they're getting an
hour it's pain maybe it's a pain in the
ass making that coffee though people are
pushies sure I'll try to dealing with
the you I don't I don't like the fact
that
Starbucks doesn't give you the option to
do it on the card you got to give cash I
know but that's what I'm saying we
should have they should have that stop
taking cash for a long [ __ ] time yeah
you know what I mean they should be like
I want to tip those guys because those
guys are in the [ __ ] you go to a nice
coffee shop it's whatever they got their
music playing they barely pay attention
like you you're acting like you're
walking into their house asking them for
a cup of [ __ ] coffee you want the uh
Aroma Blend or whatever yeah Starbucks
I'm like this is like [ __ ] trench
warfare in here you know what I mean
like people are screaming cops are
getting thrown [ __ ] yeah I want to go
here man here's five bucks enjoy yeah
you gotta give them cash you should they
that's the place that should have the
iPad that's what I'm saying if I'm not
mistaken I think they're a little up in
arms over there right now about the
wages and stuff like that that they're
grossly underpaid I could be talking out
of turn I don't know give it a goog but
yeah they should have to flip it I think
they have the highest paid they're like
they have like really good I think they
have really good everything so I think
Starbucks is one of the only I could be
wrong again but that offers the
benefits and the whole nine yards like
better than most places okay of that
nature still you still they should they
should have the iPad that's what I wrote
on there yeah a lot of places
if I remember
waiting tables it gets a little wonky
with the credit card tip because the
the business has to pay the credit card
fee or something like that I remember
there was something probably yes
probably I'd say I think like a credit
card process is like three and a half
percent or two two point five percent
yeah one of the places that would come
out of the tip yeah they take it out of
your tips that's kind of [ __ ] awesome
yeah one or two places that I worked at
not great places but
yeah
that's why everybody out there I always
say you go into a restaurant that
doesn't take reservations and is just
all cash
food's gonna be awesome yeah
food's gonna be awesome everybody's all
right you gotta really be flexing to be
able to pull that off yeah and those are
good jobs to have so everybody's like
you're not getting beat by anybody like
really [ __ ] close yeah yeah now and
he ain't getting a job there either
no that's what I'm saying those are
[ __ ] hard to come by
a couple places and out there in Queens
man
um but let's get into it gang it's a
family episode as you know when you join
the old patreon over there we will
answer your garbage question on the air
you choose uh it's just the best way to
do it we can hit up a bunch but this is
kind of the uh patreon gets top priority
yeah now what I mean this one's from
Bobby two Stone does anyone in your
family ever run for president
[Laughter]
that's a that's a little uh that's a
that's a tough look you got someone
running for any office I have a little
outside of like the aesthetic if you're
like I'm gonna show you that's a little
crazy
um
I think uh maybe like assemblyman or
something like that and the distant
distant distant person were they in
politics or was it like I'm gonna show
you that's what I mean like if you're
like in the power if you're in the
political world and you're running for
office I get that it's a political one
I'm talking about like a local level
like I'm sure I'm sure there are at
least they're involved they're not doing
it as a vendetta that's what I'm saying
they're not doing it to get back because
they got a speeding ticket yeah like
I'll show you I'm gonna take this down
from the inside type thing it's more of
like uh hey there's issues in our
community I want to fix that makes sense
yeah like local campaign commercial with
no shirt on yeah it's like yeah [ __ ]
uh Tiger King type [ __ ] you know what I
mean like really got a [ __ ] bone to a
bone to pick with somebody most of it's
bleeped out because
yeah
uh yeah that kind of [ __ ] that stuff
you're running for office that's you
know I definitely has people in my
family who are you know there's a couple
of Judges you know the DA's stuff like
that
um but it was always like in the world
of like sure local politics to whatever
to whatever sure it's never like you
know I'm gonna barricade myself in this
house and have you come get me you know
never that kind of [ __ ]
it's a guy who's like welded onto the
sides of his truck to make it quote
unquote bulletproof yeah exactly I
remember in the 90s early 2000s there
were a couple of dudes that like built
tanks in their garage sure just one day
drove out and started crushing cars I
can't that's a good time that's good
Civil Disobedience there yeah some dude
like built one in his garage and it just
blasted out one day you're talking about
Marvin himeyer who would you go to
school with them the fact you had that
talking about
no because the name of what he built is
so awesome and he built the kill Dozer
I mean was he eight years old who comes
up with that they kill Dozer yeah
yeah it was I don't think it probably
didn't end well for him in the Dozer did
it no he probably got a couple of
flashbacks
oh no he painted the inside himself yeah
oh yeah okay oh Danny yikes he's a real
DIY kind of guy
can't wait on the government for
everything
he really puts it in his own hands turns
out the sheriff's department isn't
messing around
oh yeah you like crushed some cars or
something like that was driving around
yeah and he built like three foot cement
walls around the side so it was
bulletproof yeah don't do that if you're
out there listening [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
up a whole town of Colorado dude geez
now relax run for comptroller or
something like that get a pack of
Bernies if I can go to happy hour relax
[ __ ] play a game of pool or darts or
something ain't that [ __ ] serious
couple of Cheesesteak egg rolls
straightened me out real quick down here
Pinocchio have a blue Hawaiian shout out
to Pinocchio's
um all right let's see here uh this one
is from Andy is it garbage to cover the
food stamp card with a regular debit
card that way no one's standing in line
knows I'm poor I respect it that's good
that's really good I've also um
that's chest not Checkers and I I
appreciate that I've realized some uh
uh Financial maturity or I'm just
growing up I realized because my card
got declined the other day I guess it
was like a processing thing or something
and I didn't immediately start coming up
with excuses I just feel like a little
more calm and mature I wasn't like you
[ __ ] are understand Green in that
account because I typically go to burn
the place down build my own killdozer
[ __ ] go to town on the deli but I
didn't do that I just said oh I'll try
another card
well I got a 20 on me I'll pay for it I
typically lose it real quick
start quoting account numbers and stats
call my accountant back it over the
pistachios
throwing meatballs at people
um also in the same roads from Nick I
haven't had one read yet are you garbage
if over 50 percent of your family's net
worth came from a civil action lawsuit
get in where you fit in ah this is a
kooky world you gotta get your hands on
some greenbacks how do you get the whole
family involved
could have been you know I don't know
it's all right what's a sip what is a
civil well it constitutes a civil action
lawsuit the car was talking about this
no that's a class action oh
what does it say it again civil action
lawsuit civil action lawsuit hmm sounds
like slip and fall to me yeah cases
involving personal injury battery
negligence deformation medical
malpractice ding ding ding we got a
winner yeah that's probably what it is
we'll lose a foot for the whole family
to go to college don't mind that whole
family got colonoscopies at the same
time settlement money creates a
different type of trash yeah because you
didn't it's it's like Lottery type thing
you didn't you came you're still in the
bar now you just got money to go by
WaveRunners and Mountain Dew doctor
leaves a set of scissors in here I got a
sponge in your elbow
yeah they started really counting those
now because I think too many doctors got
sued that wasn't like the 90 or 2000
they were leaving stuff in everybody I
remember watching US 60 Minutes on it I
was like 10. I was like Yo Ma go in
there again pull the plug before you let
them open so chick goes in to get her
tits done they find a desk lamp in there
bad news where my car keys at
damn dude anybody see my disc man
let's hear Phil Collins playing lowly ah
all right this one's from your deadbeat
dad uh is it garbage is your childhood
trauma as a witty username shout out to
it deadbeat dad appreciate that that's
pretty good it's got a good sense of
humor about it
um let's see
this is from Sam 10 Buck homie here
never had one red is it garbage when
you're dining and fine in a fine
establishment to point to what you want
on the menu because you don't know how
to pronounce it properly
I try to get away with it sometimes I'll
start it let me get the sugar
in your [ __ ] Trail wall with a point
and show if I'm pointing and showing I
am not confident in the pronunciation of
that yeah oh despicable loses and the
um Carnitas yeah
boiled not fried [ __ ] me up uh that's
tough that's why I don't order wine a
lot
because a lot of it I mean yeah let me
get a glass of cab or whatever but they
go oh we have these and it's like I
don't speak French you know what I mean
I'm a [ __ ] American baby with the
[ __ ] Chateau day whatever Chateau day
hey give me an IPA and zip it will ya I
know how to pronounce that how about a
chateau Coors Light let's do that in a
clean glass
yeah that's tough man I also as a guy
who's just recently expanded his uh
palette you know what I mean I'm used to
chicken fingers and stuff now that we
I've eat like going out to eat more and
stuff like that and expand it it's like
I'm definitely real [ __ ] real iffy on
the pronunciation of stuff sure she's in
a fancy place called I'll have a course
banquet I do have an eye on banquet
well it's also like my wife will ask me
stuff and I'm like I don't [ __ ] I'm goo
I Google a lot at the at the table Ah
that's okay go do a little goog yeah but
it's not just like oh what's this look
it's like why I have no idea what this
even is okay or like it'll be like this
this and a whatever sauce I got nothing
I'm [ __ ] if it ain't barbecue I don't
[ __ ] with nothing wrong with the goo
then they pop up a picture you're like
okay yeah I need visually I need to see
it sure you know for the Chinese spot's
always the best yeah give me that number
four keep it moving
I would love to get one of those the
Chinese store now the the menu with all
the pictures on it and put it where I
don't know throw it up in here somewhere
hey what's your thing going around the
internet a couple of people that got
like uh this has been this happened a
few years ago but they've been popping
back with the TVs yeah crackhead steals
a TV and then you buy it for 12 bucks
and it's the [ __ ] it's the menu for
McDonald's and that's all in place
those have been popping up a lot that's
funny uh-huh it's like yeah [ __ ]
bought this for 50 bucks wonder why it
was so cheap just says like number four
number five number six shout out to it
man yeah ain't nothing wrong with it
um all right this one's from Jesse my
brother rented a venue for a
Thanksgiving dinner but he was too cheap
to pay for the beer I had to walk up to
the bar and buy a beer for two bucks
that's tough if you're renting out the
place and you first a cat you're like a
cash Thanksgiving is nuts you're renting
out a place to have Thanksgiving that
makes sense if it's a haul or something
I mean if you don't have space for the
family at the house huge family you know
what I mean I mean like think about it
man if it's 20 20 30 person family not
very many places should house that at a
table or two yeah I remember when I was
a kid we'd be the adults would be in the
dining room you'd have the kids table in
the kitchen and there'd be there'd be
like a mutants a table now dude we'd be
in the hallway yeah literally that's
what I'm saying so imagine you've got 20
30 people whatever maybe your kitchen's
not big enough to cook for everybody
yeah you gotta figure I I respect
renting the hole I mean it's weird it's
I've never done it but I I get it hey
let's do it here but you do it proper
yeah covering cash for Thanksgiving is
rough
and that's VFW or something
now you're speaking my language it's a
bartender with a moose hat on he's got
he's got a [ __ ] gobbler going he's
probably not real cool either no working
on Thanksgiving he's a little upset but
also it's not the classiest place if
they got two dollars maybe a
Thanksgiving special you know what I
mean hey it's still happy hour happy
hours on Thursdays chicken string for
free
50 Cent oysters yikes uh that is a tough
one
um this is from worst dude this is we
were just here long time homie never had
a question right ever got in a fight at
a Waffle House
no I just I've only been to a couple as
of recent we've been in the South the
waffle houses are all right top shelf
we had top shelf service at one not that
long ago just last week you mean yeah I
remember I remember I don't know if our
survey I wouldn't top shelf I thought
she was fantastic you're a little crazy
sure
a little crazy it was early in the
morning maybe she had other coffee
she yelled at me three times
yeah
but Waffle House got a very fast mouth
yeah and those dude the teeth the two
that she had were so dark and discolored
and black it almost made me not finish
my [ __ ] hash browns which I did
though
um waffle houses are known to have some
situations in life well of course well
you go there all [ __ ] up you know what
I mean that was Denny's back in the day
for me there was always a fight at
Denny's watch a nice fight at Denny's I
was tough I mean that guy I forgot what
[ __ ] we were in North Carolina or
Georgia or something like I had the
[ __ ] heat on them too remember the
guy was sitting at the counter a big old
[ __ ] big old gun on him sit there
with Desert Eagle I wasn't [ __ ] I
wasn't making a move dude South Carolina
it was about 42 degrees out too this
guy's in [ __ ] a cut off and shorts
with a [ __ ] big old Hammer ready to
go yeah yeah if anything popped off I
knew that guy had it he had an itchy
trigger finger he was looking for a
reason I said blueberry
looking for trouble uh-huh uh shout out
to the waffle house though if you've
never been and you're in the South go
[ __ ] something else it's real Bare
Bones No Frills and the table's always
kind of dirty when you sit down sticky
menu yeah a little sticky uh probably no
heat going or air conditioning but it's
a good [ __ ] breakfast can't have a
type of spoke post Oh you mean cool guy
[ __ ] for cool guys you don't know you
need until you have it let me ask you
something I like doing cool guy stuff
you like looking cool you like cool
pocket knives you like cool grooming
stuff you like cool stuff for your home
bar yeah bespoke post box Awesome every
month shows up Bing Bang Boom you got it
it's the winter time a lot of cool stuff
in the wintertime I always like the cool
looking dudes in the winter yeah you
always remember one of them now bespoke
post I can be cool too I am cool because
they set me up for a monthly thing I'm
getting [ __ ] every goddamn month and I
haven't been telling you losers man I
got a sweet cooler now you fellas like
getting laid
talk turkey it's fantastic man I gotta
tell you to get started cooler yeah like
one of those like really cool guy the
cooler you walk up people go what is
that that's what I got okay spoky let's
go we only get one the deal was I get
the perks man uh to get started take the
quiz at box of awesome.com your answers
helped them pick the right box of
awesome for you ton of different
categories each box is valued at around
70 dollars but you pay only a fraction
of that price
um right now here it is baby you get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome.com enter the code
garbage at check out that's box of
awesome.com code garbage for 20 off your
first box box of awesome.com go garbage
do it okay let's talk about ladder
ladder Let's Get Serious is for a second
quit screwing around God damn it we're
talking about term life insurance you're
gonna die someday do yourself a favor
gang don't leave the family holding the
proverbial bag you know what I'm saying
get yourself some term life insurance
sock drawer in the back behind my Mark
McGuire rookie card I'll find my head
stash
guys ladder is 100 digital no doctors no
needles no paperwork when you apply for
three minutes
three million in coverage or less just a
few questions about your health in an
application yeah a few minutes of phone
a laptop to apply we've been over this a
million times ladder smart algorithms
work in real time to find out if you're
approved instantly so you choose there's
no infusion cancel any time get a full
refund bada bing bada boom in the first
30 days uh so go to latterlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder l-a-d-d-e-r
life.com slash garbage ladderlife.com
garbage today do it do it and when
they're that that one was a well-old
machine they were they weren't putting
them out yeah they were chopping them up
and slicing them and throwing them out
it's no D there's another the the
kitchen isn't digital it's all still
called out it's all still fire I need
three sloppy whatever you know what that
all hinders on having a good Grill man
and there ain't too many of them out
there left you can handle it can handle
that yeah crowded Waffle House sure
tickets just going off a menu I need
three sunny side up four hash browns
smothered covered tattered scattering
the guy that works the grill the best
like that like a good Grill man sees his
parole officer once a week uh checks in
on time P's clean and is in desperate
need of some dental work oh yeah that's
the guy you want slicing them up Shout
Out handling one of those long spatulas
right out to you not even we'll not make
an eye contact with anybody he's in the
zone he's seeing moves two three omelets
ahead at a time he's anticipating the
orders that guy
[Laughter]
I need three eggs but I think he's got
it on a plate already I knew
um fantastic shout out to the waffle
easy baby big fan
uh Toby have you ever ordered you ever
been in a handful of waffle Hazels
absolutely have you ever ordered
anything but breakfast at a Waffle House
Jesus Christ I didn't even know that was
a possibility on the other side of the
menu
yeah they got a couple of burgers at
Texas Tommy or something oh no way dude
those are the minimize will be the
upside down what do you stuff the
mushrooms with just out of curiosity no
you tell you one thing I've never had a
problem pronouncing anything on a Waffle
House no yeah no kidding
is that pronounced SUNY side up
I'll tell you this
uh you get a decent stake there you
could
how do I say it it'd be pretty trash is
what you're trying to say I understand
what you're saying you get a piece of
meat there yeah it's not bad steak and
somehow the grill hasn't been cleaned in
45 years you know what I mean it's got
that nice that's what I'm saying that's
what I'm saying this ain't no Michelin
star but you know what I noticed at that
Waffle House when we were there is our
good pal Tom Cassidy shout out to him
prefers his egg sunny side up I don't
trust I don't trust Sunny Side I don't
know if I've ever I've never ordered
sunny side up I don't like it I don't
like I don't like it I I just just me
personally I mean that's like a man's
The Sunny Side Up I mean that thing
could pop out and start flying away at
any minute I got a feather in mind yeah
dude yeah there we go sunny side up uh
over over medium over medium yeah you
gotta flip them out like that at a place
like that I'm going [ __ ] scramby
Danby all day
sunny side up you're putting your life
in your hands shout out to the Sunnyside
boys up there out there that's tough it
was a real man and women real men move
yeah hardcore
um all right this one's from Chris
evermelt American cheese on mashed
potatoes
I haven't but two things I love a craft
thingy and a mashed dating sure I don't
see why that wouldn't be I think I would
love that how do you do it though
microwave Mike it's got to be the
microwave
but I guess if you do a screw you put in
a bowl and then put that on top of the
bowl or a plate with a scoop and then
that on top either way I gotta be honest
I'm pretty in yeah I love cheesy mashed
potatoes oh what if what they're great
of course that's a guy who's only eating
mashed potatoes oh yeah he's been
looking away to church that thing up
yeah
yeah I remember I I wasn't always true
it wasn't always uh a given in our house
to put cheese on eggs
now what from Jump Street that wasn't a
thing I didn't learn that until like
going to diners and stuff like that what
do you mean like cheese on scrambled
eggs yeah we don't patty patty didn't
make cheesy eggs like that no should
maybe do it my mom still does my dad
would do you an omelette
sure but there would be no cheesy
scrambled eggs no and then I saw my boy
one time get his hash browns with with
cheese on him I was like I didn't know
you could do that that's pretty good uh
you wanna eat one of the coldest moves
ever done at a wedding hit me with my
both my parents were divorced before
they got together my dad's ex-wife came
to the wedding gave them an omelette pan
as the gift and it goes to my mom he
makes the best breakfast
whoa Jesus
[Laughter]
was this on an episode of Jerry Springer
or not man Jesus Christ who is it Joan
Collins
she wearing a red dress the devil in the
red dress yeah
man what a temptress why was she invited
to the wedding anyway that's weird to
begin with I didn't want to call yeah
because it's a public episode [ __ ]
home wrecker beat it I know he's moved
on to better take a hike lady
oh wow I feel like that woman like
smudges the lips to kiss you then
smudges the lipstick off your face yeah
you still have the band ah wow this is
Farberware
a good band nonetheless oh man yeah no
cheesy eggs were a fried cheesy egg like
if we were if my mom was making like a
breakfast sandwich sure an egg sandwich
that was through a craft singing on that
or sure we talked about this briefly I
think where craft singles orange or
yellow in your house orange really of
course whoa the orange ones the white
ones are weird I don't know why I didn't
white orange you only got it like orange
cheese to me was an outdoor thing
were you white or did you craft singles
yeah I didn't know about white cheese
whoa until like three months ago no I
mean we would get we would get American
from the store it's like White Slice
thin man it's it's Orlando Lakes it
should no no we would get from the deli
counter I know yeah a lot of times in
Philly it was phenomenal but as a as a
little little kid it was it was it was
the craft singles that were in there and
they were orange and even before that
we would get that shoe box full of
Velveeta
let me tell you something you put some
of that in scrambled eggs oh yeah I mean
fake cheese what are you doing call the
office come on
I wouldn't mind now that I think about
it doing like what cheese whiz eggs
probably pretty good man that cheese was
has a Tang to it that will [ __ ] it'll
make your eyes roll back in your fresh
bottle of that
dip anything in there I remember once at
least the pretzel rods in there I
remember if I found out man I was I
[ __ ] heated up a whole a big bowl of
it at my house by myself
you're drinking it how do I heat up a
big bowl and all we had was [ __ ]
um those not the Ritz the ones we were
just talking about the toll house or the
uh the clubhouse no the townhouse
townhouse yeah those Town those oval
Townhouse crackers dude oh my God I made
a soup by the end of it because they
kept breaking I was putting I just was
eating it with a spoon and crumbled up
crackers I had about two trees screaming
cans of coke mod knew nothing else
nothing about she came home I go what's
for dinner
I had my auntie past earlier let's go
oh man fat little kids left on we'll
figure it out oh I always figured it out
I remember my next girlfriend of mine
said that to me she's like no matter
what is in my house
you always find something you always put
because I'm we have a different mind I'm
thinking about it like a week in advance
I'll catalog everything I know we have
the croutons where can I go from there
yeah she has croutons she has ranch
dressing and shredded cheese that's all
I need huh I remember uh man there was a
time I was making that's all you need I
was making plates of [ __ ] homemade
nachos in the microwave in the microwave
with craft singles just on top of
[ __ ] Tostitos oh my god dude if you I
would watch the microwave just stop it
at the right time before the cheese got
too old you're an artist oh man I felt
like I was working the girl at a Waffle
House the whole world shut down behind
me I was just sure it was just me and
then hyper focused
um all right this one's from Connor 10
on me first time question how garbage is
it if your Mom leaves the Christmas tree
up year-round
crazy bad but redecorates it for
different holidays throughout the year
Valentine's Day St Patrick's Day Fourth
of July and so on
simply because her and her dad are too
lazy to take it down it can't be in the
living room
this is listen that's got real sun room
Vibes which I I don't all right leaving
it up trash for sure trash yeah but
apparently you're taking the decorations
off and you'll read that that's fun and
if it's in a different room I don't want
it next to the TV no if it's in like
debate hey we keep it in the basement
it's out it's in the spare room it's
whatever I can understand that's fun
you're decorating for Thanksgiving and
uh and St Patty's Day and Valentine's
Day I can kind of get behind that would
you decorate for that too what was what
was the pieces decoration so she still
does Halloween Halloween Thanksgiving a
little transition a little bit Yeah
there's like a turkey with a or like you
know if the kids have like the hands
whatever the kids made at school we made
net we made before the kids the
grandkids make now Christmas would there
be a couple of things up for Valentine's
Day and would you get Valentine's
Valentine's Day presents from your mom
um no but I would get her a nightie
every year
from Adam and Eve
would get like a card with maybe like a
five bucks for five something small some
of those conversation Hearts which I
love yeah I mean what do you have
[ __ ] taking those like Percocets
those cinnamon candles cinnamon Hearts
um pinch we would and then St Patrick's
Day
yeah but not a whole bunch those were
just very like oh two or three things
yeah yeah yeah yeah Christmas you would
go all out of yeah but like even more
than you would now thinking back it was
a lot she would read like we have like
uh that big window in the front all the
way up top on the second floor and she
would do like a street landscape in
there right like three or four dolls all
earning Street lamps there was fake snow
it was a lot it was looking back we
didn't go for the animatronics we didn't
trust that stuff our stuff was always we
would lay in bed and you would hear them
at night
I'm turning scare me I'd rather be in
the [ __ ] crawl space dude [ __ ] that
turn over one's Lane making a move on me
yeah now I'm your stepsister what
classic white lights in the windows that
was always that was that was always a
fun Sunday fight for the foleys getting
out the Christmas stuff getting screamed
at putting the trains up to this to that
then at the end ah be nice putting it
back was the worst we'll save that for
our uh our Christmas
Extravaganza did you get my present yet
no for the Christmas Extravaganza what
do you mean you already got it from me
no oh yeah I know yeah oh did I purchase
yours yet no what do you want to hear
no not yet okay have you got mine uh
it's in it's in the works for real
uh-huh
better be a couple zeros behind it
T-Bone you're out this year oh that's
good I'm getting you gas money to go
pick up the sound bar from your cousin's
place shout out to be girls
guys if you're looking for if you want
to hear the cool sounds of a sound bar
and you're in North Wildwood hit off B
Kells I'll have you over the bill over
the garage Tiki Bar watch the game we
just it was just discussed whether we
should throw that out or not
not to hurt your feelings oh well not to
hurt your feelings but but I keep saying
we hooked it up wrong
and I keep being reassured that it
wasn't hooked up wrong
but it's on the chopping block just so
you know
well wait a minute just ruined Toby's
months what are you talking about I I
have his Christmas present in my house
you gotta keep it so that when you get
evicted the boys have something some
work to do exactly
be real careful with that hey that
thing's a piece of [ __ ] don't you break
it I almost threw that out
laughs
so there's something to defend myself
with like when the sheriff comes they
kick me out
you're swinging it
is that a sound bar I don't know what it
is like what the hell is that my
soundbar killed Dozer get out of here
um all right this one's uh for
Millennial G Costanza
um are you garbage if your parents
refuse to get rid of the boxes of VHS
Disney movies in the basement because
they're worth a lot of money these days
ouch bonus points if your dad still has
a Star Wars bedsheet from when he was a
kid kept in a vacuum sealed bag that
might be worth a couple of bucks
yeah I mean we can find get on a Google
and I had a set of those too man there's
no way those are I mean they might be
little boy you probably get them from
you probably got more money from
perverts who want little bully sheets
than a Star Wars collector just my guess
do a little sniffing now that might be
worth a little bit but the Disney movies
too they were real remember they were
real tight with that [ __ ] they wouldn't
release all of them at once or you
couldn't get certain ones on the on VHS
and [ __ ]
and that might be worth a couple of two
for some psycho out there dude these
Star Wars sheets are moving yeah what
are we talking 9.99
nine million 999 damn I had a pair of
those too I did I'd be rich right now oh
yeah these things are no 46 Walt Disney
46 Disney VHS
uh is going for 152 bucks 46 of them
yeah that's three bucks a clip okay and
that's on eBay yikes
it's like the black market yeah that's
no good I don't think they're collectors
maybe certain ones are probably worth
but as a whole
it's like baseball cards yeah you know
what I mean as a whole there ain't ain't
worth Squad douche we just crippled that
guy's family's net worth
kids aren't going to college see I told
you Randy
shout out to a good Randy by the way
um all right let's see here this one
doesn't make sense to me but I'm not a
culinary uh uh Institute student this is
from Eric just became a 10 homie is it
garbage to take the fat off a piece of
chicken to make butter to save money oh
it's called Schmaltz
it's called trash is what it's called
it's what they call it Schmaltz Schmaltz
I don't I don't know it's not my cup of
tea I thought butter was I mean that's
like Lord that's not butter right it's
just Eastern European move oh man it
looks like blood Runway there used to be
a place and my wife ever tries that
we're out there used to be a place
downtown called sami's Romanian and they
would give you bread on the table but
they'd give you Schmaltz instead of
butter it's sitting it's tough I don't
like anything about that that's tough I
just ruined my appetite
um
all right let's see here this one's from
Andrew uh
um is it garbage if you had to use a
generator so your family could run all
of their Appliance in the house as a kid
the reason being the house was a former
Amish house that wasn't hooked up to the
grid ouch
who buys an Amish house yeah there's got
to be other houses you can buy
than one that was previously Amish are
generators expensive to run that's
running on gas right
I guess I mean yeah I don't know
uh it doesn't make any sense to me
where are you living how many blow
dryers that's a lot of toast you're
making
[Laughter]
breakfast for 20. I mean how nice could
an Amish house be probably pretty nice I
mean the craftsmanship I'll give you
that but the the amenities
everything's added after they left true
all the lights are put in after they
left yeah that don't make no sense
aftermarket refrigerator it's on the
outside of the house all the outlets are
all probably [ __ ]
not great yeah I think I'll take out all
the wires none of them are in the walls
all the wires are exposed it would it
would be all extension cords that's all
well they're not using drywall either
that's all wooden walls is that what
they do they use drywall I doubt it yeah
they're all plastered they're all woodsy
huh well they probably don't even have
drywall they're not hanging decorations
yeah they are pictures the Amish who
takes the picture it's still their soul
what are you talking about Amish don't
take pictures could be a drawing
all right man
I'll give you that you keep moving the
goal post on this you've never been in
an Amish house you don't know I have
where in Lancaster when a couple years
ago I was just gonna keep lying all
right sounds good bought a pie
and one of those uh fireplaces
all right let's do this and then we
gotta roll
um this is from publi if I'm pronouncing
that correctly got a weird one which I
love me and my wife have been arguing
the past few weeks over how you're
supposed to get in the shower do you
enter from the closest to the shower
head or the furthest from the shower
head this is genius okay I can't believe
this hasn't come up yet because this is
very this show let's talk about this to
me there's one right way and then the
other way is psychopath but that's just
me and we've realized over discussions
like this before me and you don't always
see eye to eye okay
when you're about to take a shower you
turn the shower on before you get in or
you get in and turn it on what what it
is America you turn it on let it run for
10 minutes
[ __ ] go out grab a cup of coffee 10
minutes make sure there's no water for
my grandchildren I don't want anybody
[ __ ] I don't want any pulling the
wool over my eyes I want the hottest
water you got we agree on that yes let
the water run let the water run of
course okay
um if you tell me what I think I'm
supposed to get the wrinkles out of my
shirt I got a big show tonight I got a
hot date with a broad I get in
head side
by the spout yes yeah that's crazy
that's that's nuts to me wait are you
kidding me in the back and you enter
like a gentleman
yes you're joking no I thought for sure
we'd all be on the same page no you go
what what are you talking about the way
you're hiding in there that's nuts no in
his defense there's nowhere for him to
hide from that's also true you should
come down from the top
you go in the back way uh-huh that's for
all you ladies out there too okay okay
hahaha
that's her a couple of drinks they had a
rear-facing camera if you catch me okay
then if that's the way you're supposed
to do it [ __ ] why
is the fact
that you're really stretching here
you're hoping you're hoping a good a
good argument comes to your head why is
the fact you're a butthead
then why is it a fact that if you have a
glass shower the shower door the
entrance is always closer to the faucet
it's not a fact yes it is yes it is no
it's not oh my God all right I got this
it always is no it's not
uh it's crazy I don't know what you mean
listen all right maybe like a real nice
hotel yeah they had we were just in one
in [ __ ] Atlanta where it didn't have
a door and the opening was in the back
normally I would just put up a
screenshot of a singular option of an
image we're trying to display on the
show I'm just gonna do the whole the
whole the whole Google image search
where the door is away from this packet
it's just um yeah I think you go right
in because then if you have to adjust it
you're right there at the things that's
crazy
I also think for uh maybe we got to why
your floor so wet all the time for
Splash purposes
you can't open it you open it and get in
the water it's [ __ ] spraying
everywhere you get it you oh you get in
close the curtain or the door then enter
the water upon invitation I've always
the foleys have always gone in head
first how do you know what they're doing
you and your Ma's showering a lot
because where would I learn it from I'd
learn it from them I don't know where
are you going now our shower has at my
mom's has a glass door one doesn't open
and one opens out and that is the one
that's right near the the uh I know but
also the toilet the toilet's right there
I know that is the toilets right there
so you wouldn't be able to get in so
that's just that specific thing is you
have to get in there because you don't
have an option because you got to tie a
little shoebox I never thought of that
uh-huh we do have a tiny little shoe box
mm-hmm
what do you have now a curtain or a door
curtain curtain family and you're still
going you know what's funny now that I
realize it it goes
hang on it goes the shower wait hold on
I've I've been in many I don't know
let's call it three million arguments
with the big man over the past 12 years
of our friendship
he knows he's wrong here he's because
he's he's realizing stuff hold on it
goes oh man all right here's a real
quiet here's the shower this lighter
represents the shower okay all right the
the the the shower heads the metal part
is the top of the lighter then you got
to how many things are going on in this
bathroom you got the turret over here
okay and then you have the sink is right
there by the by the head yeah so you
still sneak in between the sick what
dude I do no
you sneak in between the sink and the
tub yeah no that's your that's you're
right you get him from the back
holy [ __ ] uh-huh you're close to going
through the back
whoa
[Laughter]
yeah man that's psychopath Behavior to
just jump in the waterfall like that
really yeah I've I mean it doesn't even
seem logical to me in anything so what
do they do they didn't say they said him
and his wife have been arguing so one
does one one does the other I would
assume the guy in the from the back is
going what are you doing you're getting
[ __ ] water all over the place
huh you always say that is a big issue
for you too the water's everywhere it's
everywhere because you got the door open
because you're trying to get in the wall
and you could jump it right in the water
you get in from the back enter you do it
if it's a little too high you do the
reach around I wonder what she does
huh
man I had no idea yeah look at that it's
a whole other world for you out there
I'm still gonna keep doing it that way I
don't know try it next time it's cold
back there no not if you let it run for
long enough
it's cold back there and there's also
not cold back the fear of being scalded
I don't want to be scalded what do you
mean by the water yeah well you do it do
a hand check before you get in listen
the hand check doesn't know what it's
going to feel like when it hits my my
you should have a Supple back man I get
on the the back of my ass will burn if
they get that's the man that's the most
tender skin ever what I like to do with
that never seen sunlight my thing comes
off I have a thing that comes off and I
turn it up a little bit and I get under
the gooch get in there blast it I like
that burn okay guys
with your shower head do you adjust it
do you point it down or do you have it
pointing out we've gone over this my
current one is in the middle
which I do like I adjust it as I go yeah
I'll move it I'll I'll move it I usually
I always check to make sure it's not
[ __ ] point you gotta take one to the
head right when you get in [ __ ]
brains all over the back wall yeah like
somebody's dad cleaning their gun I make
sure that thing's pointed away yeah you
got to adjust yeah yeah always make sure
that wow get it from the front I thought
freak I knew some I knew I knew we
weren't gonna see I thought for sure you
don't see eye to eye on most there's
like 12 things that we really agree on
that's why we do differently when I ask
you guys if you turn the water on I was
like oh we'll definitely I'll be on the
same page with this once I got the one
two three on that
you go in the back especially a control
freak like you I would think you want to
get in there and have your hands it's
not a wrestling match
get in there get him in the head that's
right you want to get in there and have
can have access I control it before I
get in I make sure it's okay I got this
is good and then I enter
I never got in from that's insane to me
I've never done it I want to make a call
on this to who I don't know the
president I can't ask my mom because of
the way that one that one
that's crazy yeah well
you have to do some soul searching over
the next couple of days but we'll you
know he'll figure it out but we gotta
wrap her up here
ladies and gentlemen there's a we've
broken H Foley it only took 300 episodes
and this guy is
it looks like you've seen Jesus yeah you
learned something here you know what I'm
saying my whole life has been a lie all
I know is I've been saying that for
years you're really getting the back too
everyone dude everyone's Gotto does your
mom and dad get in the back I'm not
showering with them anymore
gang we love you we'll see you next week
peace